[CHIME]
SHELMITH KARIUKI: It has been
fourteen years since the phrase,
"Data is the new
oil," was first used.
This phrase was
coined by Clive Humby,
implying that, just as oil
needs to be refined into gas,
chemicals, plastics,
et cetera, data
must be broken down and
analyzed for it to have value.
But what if it is not?
Of what value is the data
if it is open, accessible,
but not usable?
Hi, my name is Shelmith
Kariuki, and I'm here
to talk about a small project
I embarked on in March 2020.
rKenyaCensus is a
package that contains
the 2019 Kenya population
and housing census results.
The population census
exercise was held in August,
and this was the
first time that Kenya
was using technology for
both cartographic mapping
and enumeration.
The survey questionnaire
about areas
such as population
characteristics, agriculture,
education, information,
communication, and technology,
henceforth referred
to as ICT, et cetera.
This data was published
in four PDF files which
can be found on
the Kenya National
Bureau of Statistics website.
Now, is this data open?
Yes, it is available
on the website.
Is it accessible?
Yes, anyone can download it.
But is it usable in
its current format?
But why do we even care?
Why is usability important?
Let us look at one of
the aspects covered
in the survey, ICT.
We're going to look
at the influence
that ICT has had on education
in Kenya during the COVID
pandemic.
But first, a few statistics.
According to a new
report by UNICEF,
two out of three
school-age children
do not have internet
access at home.
In fact, the number
of unconnected pupils
is higher in Africa
and Asia as compared
to the rest of the world.
The first COVID case
was announced in Kenya
on 12th March.
And two days after,
the government
announced closure of
schools, and institutions
were encouraged to move
their learning online.
The Ministry of Education
also made a directive
for the curriculum
teaching to be
delivered via
radio, TV, YouTube,
and other digital platforms.
And so, online learning began.
Kenyans adapted very quickly.
One University trained
their students and stuff
and also entered
into a partnership
with a mobile network
operator to ensure
that their staff received
cheaper data bundles
specifically for e-learning.
Several other institutions
did their best to hitch
to their government directive.
Entertainment programs were
aired on TV during school hours
and young kids
quickly learned how
to use tools such as
Zoom and Google Hangout.
But then, online learning was
not going well for everyone.
Leaders from semiarid
areas came out
claiming that online
learning in their areas
was just but a fallacy
because the area has
lacked basic infrastructure.
So what basic
infrastructure is required
for smooth online learning?
First, one would need a
laptop or a mobile phone
to access materials in
an electronic format.
And these devices
have to actually
be connected to the internet
so that you can actually
access this information
and electricity is
needed to power both.
A lot of students
took to social media
to complain that online learning
was not working for them.
A lot claimed that they
lacked their minimum basic
requirements needed to
partake in online learning.
Electricity has also
been a problem in Kenya,
even for us who have
access to electricity.
It's not reliable.
I'm actually hoping that I'll
be done with this presentation
by the time lights go off.
You can visit the
Kenya power Twitter
handle to just see
more of the complaints
that we channel
through that platform,
complaining about blackouts
day in and day out.
Many families do not have
the devices and internet
access that enable children to
take part in remote schooling.
Let's take an example
of two extreme cases.
Manzi comes from
an average family.
She has a bedroom of
her own in the house.
Manzi's father pays for internet
at the end of each month
and he recently purchased
a new laptop for her.
Manzi attends
"Shule Kubwa", which is
a university based in the
capital city of Kenya, Nairobi.
Chali, on the other hand,
comes from a humble background.
His parents are not able
to pay school fees for him
and so he has to depend on
the area's bursary fund.
And after emerging top in the Kenya
secondary national
examination, Chali
got a scholarship to
also attend "Shule Kubwa".
So Chali and Manzi,
together with some
of the friends they grew up
with, are in the same class.
And while in school,
they are subjected
to the same conditions--
the same lecture
room, the same lecture period,
the same exam, and so on.
But what happens now
that are at home?
Well, Manzi is
actually very happy.
She gets to seclude herself in
her room during class sessions,
and while on her break,
she's able to enjoy
her favorite comedy on Netflix.
But then for Chali,
he's actually depressed.
He's even thinking of repeating
the current class because he
feels he has been left behind.
After six months,
schools reopened
for a small subset of
students-- those preparing
for the national examinations.
In Kenya, national
examinations take place
at the end of each year.
Now, an effective
education response
to the COVID-19
pandemic needs to be
built on evidence and data.
For example, what do we
know about our population?
How many families own
radios and televisions?
And do children actually
use and actually
learn from these
online platforms?
And that's why the development
of rKenyaCensus was important.
Development of this package
involved three steps.
The first one was downloading
the data from the International
Bureau of Statistics website.
The second one involved
cleaning, scraping, cleaning,
and manipulating the data.
I used the tabulator package
to scrape the data and tidyverse
and tabulizer functions for
cleaning and manipulating it.
The third step was the
actual package development.
And I'm very grateful to the
authors of devtools, testthat,
and usethis, who have made
package development very easy.
I'm also grateful to Hadley and Jenny
for the R packages book that
is written in such a
simple language, such
that it is easy to understand
some of the concepts covered.
For consistency, the datasets
were named in a similar manner
as the tables in the
published documents.
So V1_T2.1 is actually
Table 2.1 in Volume 1.
Data cleaning and
manipulation skills
are really important
in this task.
I had to deal with a lot of
drilling and leading spaces,
extra white spaces,
blank spaces,
and other weird characters.
I also needed to
restructure the data
by generating new variables
that distinguished counties
from sub-counties.
I'm grateful to the R4DS
community, especially
Scott and Stephen,
who are of great help
when I encountered
errors while coding.
Well, I still battle
with projects up to date.
I also created a small
shiny app where anyone,
especially those who do not
use R can download the data
in either .csv or .xlxs format.
Now, could some
of this data have
helped us to determine
whether Kenya
was ready for online learning?
Let's have a look.
This map shows the
proportion of households
where the main type of
lighting is electricity.
The data can be found
in Volume 4, Table 2.19.
So in essence, in the data,
it's going to be V4_2.19.
The darker the region,
the higher the proportion.
The darkest region
is the capital city
of Kenya, which is Nairobi.
Most regions in
the semiarid areas,
that's the light
yellow regions, use
either burned wood,
torches, or paraffin lamps
as a source of light.
Chali comes from
one of these areas.
In case anyone is
curious, these maps
are created using
sf and ggplot2.
The pattern is the
same when we look
at access to
computers or laptops
and usage of the internet.
Semiarid and regions
that have high-population
based in the rural areas
tend to be at a disadvantage.
There's no way Chali could have
reaped the benefits of online
learning as much as
Manzi wouldn't have,
even at a bare minimum.
If this kind of analysis
was available beforehand,
the insights obtained
could have helped
the government and stakeholders
make better decisions regarding
learning during
the COVID pandemic.
The data has been used by
the International Center
for Humanitarian Affairs,
which is part of the Red Cross,
to assess COVID-19
high-risk areas in Kenya.
It's my prayer
that most entities
will adopt this data to
develop insights that will help
drive development in Kenya.
And to conclude, we
have only touched
on the ICT part of this data.
In essence, only 2
out of 74 tables.
Imagine how much
information we could
get if we analyzed
all the census data,
and imagine how much more
information and insights
we could get if we
converted all the data sets
that align in various websites
into machine-readable formats
that are easy to analyze.
Insights obtained
from this data will
help the country prepare itself
better for the next calamity.
R is an open source language and there
are so many learning resources
online.
It's up to us as our
developers and our users
to use the knowledge
and skills we
have to develop tools that will
help us in solving problems
that exist in our society.
Thank you for listening to me.
Questions are welcome.
[CHIME]